the margarine commercial capital of
Lagos is drowning in waste there's so
much of it that drainage systems and
waterways get blocked which creates a
serious flooding risk chamaco new wanted
to change that she's the founder of
recycle coins a company that creates
incentives to recycle waste such as
plastic bottles & pure water sashay from
pure water sashay to pellets and finally
to shopping bags rather than throwing
away the pure water stash after taking
the content and clog in our last field
and drainages and waterways and nutrient
our streets you can actually use them as
raw materials for a new product the
Cockney sends out a so-called waste
Buster to register households and
businesses it picks up everything that
can be recycled including plastic
bottles glass bottles cans and cardboard
in return the participants receive
points they can redeem for household
items every time they come emeka bath
runway points and they come three or
four times in a moon it's probably the
preferred because they are making
everywhere to be clear clean four mile
area one pet bottle for example equals
one point for 5,000 points or 5,000
bottles recyclers can get a cat on of
noodles for example that may not seem
like much but for many people every bit
helps the waste is sorted and crushed
and so to recycling plant that allows
the company to turn a profit turning
trash into cash is an idea that Roma
corner hopes will catch on and she wants
to raise environmental awareness we
usually introduced Alicia cycling to a
community to come to different
committees by first of all organizing or
what we call the green rallies where we
you know unclog the clogged drainage
ease and little streets retrieve and
clean and as we are doing that we are
equally teaching the community dwellers
about waste recycling starting their
waste in that we stop the ways that even
had generated in that exercise that help
is urgently needed league of state
produces
is about 10,000 tons of waste per day
too much for the municipal waste
collection to handle resident appreciate
the opportunity to reduce the impact on
the environment and so the local
companies as a bank we produce quite a
lot of waste and now instead of that
just going to some regular landfill and
polluting the environment we find that
we are being an even more socially
responsible citizen because we know that
working with a trusted partner like
recycle points the waste the huge
amounts of waste that we we do produce
as a bank ends up somewhere good more
and more people are joining recycled
points chamaco nuisance the venture has
been a success we have about six
thousand households when you start on
our platform and that's on that the
household recycling scheme because we
have both the house for recycling scheme
the corporate recycling skin and the
school recycling scheme because we want
we took this to the school's to able to
catch the young ones as early as
possible to start that culture change
from from at Le stage and it's been a
fantastic ride so far today just a small
fraction of the legacies waste is
recycled that leaves recycle points with
plenty of opportunity to expand its
business
you